good morning my name is Lisa white and
I'm a software engineer at Twitter and I
work on our real-time streaming products
at Twitter we process hundreds of
millions of tweets per day if you do the
math out that's thousands of tweets per
second and we process those in real-time
without ever missing a single tweet so
we built an architecture called power
track and power tracks processes this
massive amount of data both quickly and
reliably power track allows our
customers to create a customizable set
of tweets so that they can get the
tweets that are relevant to them and the
reason that we do this is that for for
most of our customers handling the
entire entire firehose of tweets is a
lot to handle there are a lot of people
tweeting publicly at any given moment
and handling all of that in real time
would be a lot so we allow our customers
the ability to filter based on the
tweets that are important to them so
that they can get the percentage of
tweets that they care about so we do all
the heavy lifting so that they can get
there maybe 1% of the firehose of tweets
that are important to them so there are
a couple of different core use cases
that that you might have heard about one
would be some resource institutions
might be looking for data around public
health so that they can respond
accordingly there might be different
customers that are building different
customer service tools and there we also
have customers that are looking for
signals around natural disasters so that
they can respond accordingly so
oftentimes our customers will connect to
our api's and then bill deliver their
data to their software so that they can
do further analysis on the raw data that
we deliver so as a software engineer on
the product I'm excited to share with
you the architecture of what we built ok
so at a high level the power track
architecture
has a couple of different things that we
took into consideration with the design
the first is how we filter data at scale
so as I mentioned we're processing
thousands of tweets at it per second and
in real-time and so we have to figure
out how to make this scale and how to be
able to filter in real-time how we
ensure data fidelity so many of our
customers our enterprise customers and
dropping tweets on the ground is not
okay so we have to make sure to give
them all of the tweets we have system
redundancies because as you know in
production it's pretty common or not
pretty common but it happens that things
go wrong and you can't plan on things
being perfect all the time so we have
redundancy in order to ensure that in
the case that things go wrong we have a
back-up plan because we're processing in
real-time we have to figure out how to
apply customer stream configuration
changes and then lastly we manage we
have multiple data centers so we have to
figure out how to manage the state of
our customer applications across these
data centers so at a high level the
input into the product power track that
I work on is the public firehose so
basically all public tweets that are
happening in real time and ultimately we
deliver data to our customers and the we
have a couple layers of our application
the first of which is a filtering layer
so this layer allows customers to have
customizable rule sets so that they can
filter only on the tweets that are
important to them and then that passes
the data along to the streaming layer
which then does some additional
processing and also renders the data out
to the customer and so it gets written
via HTTP streaming to the to the
customer and so there they have a
persistent connection to us so they'll
connect one time and then they'll stay
connected for you know maybe days or
maybe even a week until our next deploy
so they'll reconnect when we do a deploy
but or if there's some kind of network
click but for the most part they're
staying connected all the time getting
the tweets as they happen in real time
and so the customer can manage their
their rule set that dictates which
tweets they get through a REST API and
so this is our rules API and it allows
them to be able to create rules and
delete rules and then this thing gets
applied to the filtering layer in real
time so the customer doesn't have to
reconnect in order to get the updated
rule set which is helpful for them
because then they don't have to worry
about missing data during the time that
they're disconnected but it does it does
provide a little bit of a challenge for
us to figure out how to apply those
configuration changes in real time so
the first piece that I'd like to dive
into is the filtering layer and so as I
mentioned we're processing thousands of
tweets per second and that's just our
base volume we also have to be able to
handle large events like a big sporting
event like the Super Bowl where a lot of
people are tweeting more than just our
base volume and so we have to figure out
how to make this scale for some
customers like those who are in the
financial industry milliseconds matter
and so we can't deliver the data
extremely late so I'm going to be
talking about filtering and how we make
that scale to all of our customers and
keep up with the real-time volume okay
so you might be wondering what I mean by
a customizable rule set so this is a
really simple example of a customer rule
so we have a filtering language that our
customers use and certain operators that
they're allowed to use so this rule
would filter tweets that are from lm/w
which is my twitter handle and it either
has mentions or is a retweet so it
either mentions another user or the
tweet itself is a retweet of another
tweet and then there's an implicit and
between the from lm/w and the next part
and so essentially this tweet would get
applied to the customers rules in
real-time and then as tweets come
through the firehose tweets that match
this rule would result in the data that
they get so this is a quick example of
two tweets that would match this rule so
the one on the left you can see that is
from me it's a tweet that I tweeted
it also has a mentioned it mentions
another user whose chewkey so this would
match that rule the one on the right
would also match so when we retweet the
tweet that creates a new tweet so I
retweeted this tweet from Twitter
Boulder that's on the right and because
it's both from me and is a retweet that
retweet of the original tweet would go
through the fire hose would go through
my would go through any stream with this
rule as well so we do this
programmatically in real time and this
is an example of the ast the abstract
syntax tree of how we programmatically
would walk through the rule so this one
is pretty simple so we'd start with the
and and then we can check whether a
tweet is from lm/w
then we can move on to the or and then
traverse through each of the children of
the or and check whether it has mentions
there is a retweet and you might notice
that there are some optimizations that
can be made here for example if the
tweet is not from Ellen W then then the
whole rule is going to be false we don't
have to continue over to the or and keep
traversing through the tree similarly in
the or if we determine that has mentions
is true we can just call the whole or
true and we don't have to keep
traversing through the tree so this is
called boolean shirt's short-circuiting
and this is helpful but it's not that
helpful so as I mentioned we're
processing thousands of tweets per
second and we also have customers that
have hundreds of South but can't have
hundreds of thousands of rules in each
of those rules is most likely a lot more
complex than this it probably it can
have up to 2048 characters and we don't
have a limit to the number of clauses
that can be in there so these rules can
get pretty complex in traversing through
the entire tree of every single one of
our customer rules for every tweet that
comes through would be pretty CPU
intensive so we have a mechanism to be
able to speed this up and this is where
predicate indexing comes in so the idea
behind predicate indexing is that we are
trying to quickly disqualify rules from
being matches
and this limits the number of full
evaluations which are the tree walks we
just looked at that we have to do so the
way that we do this is every customer
rule is indexed based on the match type
of the clauses it contains so as an
example if someone we're looking for the
term Strange Loop then we would index
strange and then we could we could also
index loop and so then those two terms
would get added into the index and then
any tweet that matches those would then
move on to be considered for full
evaluation and I'll go into more detail
in a couple slides about how we actually
go about choosing what gets in the index
but at its core what predicate indexing
is trying to do is it's trying to weed
out rules that wouldn't match anyway so
essentially we're trying to narrow down
our rule set so that we don't have to do
a full evaluation on every single rule
okay so to put this in other words the
rule evaluation is broken down into a
two-step process so when a tweet comes
through the firehose the first step is
to check the index and check whether the
rule matches anything that's that's
whether the tweet matches any of the
indices and then if it does then that
narrows it down to a smaller set of
rules for which we put through full
evaluations so as an example let's say
that a customer has a hundred thousand
rules then we add each of these rules to
the index and this might be this is most
likely more than a hundred thousand
because we have to have every rule in
the index but most rule is going to have
more than one thing indexed because we
have to make sure that logically if the
rule is going to evaluate to true the
index also evaluates to true so we'll
have more terms in the index and then
when a tweet comes through we'll
evaluate the tweet against the index and
then that will give us a smaller set of
rules for which we have to do a full
evaluation so you might be thinking well
this seems to be over complicating it
and you're adding in another step but
actually because the indexing is so much
checking the index is so
much faster than doing the full
evaluation this actually saves a ton of
time and saves a lot of CPU usage and
speeds things up and we definitely see
that in code when we pick a app or index
and we end up doing a lot more full
evaluations and we would see system
issues so the index is is way faster
than the rule evaluation as I mentioned
so then we can cut down on the time
where we're swimming in CPU okay so now
you may be wondering what we actually
index and how we choose what we index
well essentially we're trying to pick
whatever is least likely to occur and
the reason that we're trying to choose
whatever is least likely to occur is
because we're trying to narrow down the
number of full evaluations that we have
to do so if we so if we were to pick
something that's highly likely then we
wouldn't be narrowing anything down and
we would end up doing a lot more full
evaluations so in this case we have a
couple of options for what we could
index on so we could index for an and
you only have to index one side and that
is because either one of those being
false results in the and being false so
you only need one of them to guarantee
that the index being true results in it
being a potential match for the full
evaluation so in this case we have a
choice of indexing on from lm/w or
indexing on the or clause but for an or
clause you have to index every term in
there and that's because any one of
those being true results in the entire
or being true so for it to actually
follow logically that if the index is
true the or if the rule is true the
index is also true then you need to
index everything that's in the or so in
this case we can we could index has
mentioned and is retweet the the problem
with indexing those two terms is that
then when we evaluate a tweet any tweet
that either has a mentions or is a
retweet would matter
the index which is a lot of tweets that
either have mentions or are retweets so
we would end up doing a lot of full
evaluations alternatively we can index
from lm/w and although I tweet a decent
amount
I don't tweet nearly as much as has
mentioned and is retweet so by indexing
on from lm/w only we'd be able to cut
down the amount of full of eight full
evaluations we have to do by a huge
amount because we'd only have to do full
evaluations for the tweets that match
from lm/w so in essence doing this
predicate indexing allows us to cut down
on the number of full evaluations that
we have to do which are the full tree
walks and that allows us to save a lot
of time so this shows you if you're
following along but in this case we'd
index from lm/w so this helps a lot and
it saves a lot of CPU however it's not
quite enough we are still trying to
handle all of the rules for all of our
customers and keep up with all of this
data in real time so we had to think
about other ways to scale our filtering
as well so the next piece that I'm going
to talk about is more related to the
architecture so at a high level again
this is our architecture the input is
the public firehose of tweets that is
then moved into a filtering layer where
the filtering layer filters for our
customers and then the streaming layer
renders out and outputs that via is she
be streaming to the customer okay so
each of the filter apps or each of the
filter the filtering layer is broken out
into different stacks where each stack
filters for a set of different customers
so in this example you can see that
stack one is filtering for customers one
two and three stack two is filtering for
four and five etc so this allows us to
break our customers out into different
stacks so that as our customer base
grows we can simply scale the stacks
with our customer base and we've used
this in the past when we've just
grown in our number of customers and had
to add more stacks we were able to do
that pretty easily so in addition to
that each of these stacks is processing
a full firehose because they're
filtering for a different customer set
and each one wants their full set of
tweets that matches but within each
stack we have a set of apps as well so
in step one in this example let's say we
have three apps so each of those nodes
would be reading in one third of the
firehose of tweets and then each of
those would all be filtering for all of
the customers one two and three and then
writing the data down to the streaming
player so by sharing the load where
we're allowing ourselves to be able to
handle big spikes and tweets and things
like that by sharing it across three
nodes and the way that we handled this
technically is by using a messaging cue
so in Twitter we use a messaging cue
called event bus and this is a Kafka
like messaging cue so just a quick show
of hands does anyone use Kafka before
okay cool so it's a decent amount of
people here so so essentially each of
these stacks would have the same
subscriber ID as as you'd call it in
Kafka and by using the same identifier
each of the nodes within each stack
would be able to share the full copy of
the firehose and so stacks 1 2 and 3
would independently keep track of where
they're at in the queue so that each one
gets its own copy whereas the nodes
within stack 1 I'll share the same
identifier so that they can keep keep
their place together and all share the
same firehose effectively and so one
thing that this allows us to do is as
tweet volume changes we can scale our
stacks up and down similarly as we
improve filtering in different ways and
see different kinds of improvements with
our filtering algorithm then we might
need less nodes per per stack so we can
have that ability to be able to adjust
sit and so we have a dashboard that we
use to be able to do the stack
management and to be able to control the
number of nodes per stack and also how
many stacks we have and which customers
are assigned etc so in addition to
filtering being very important data
fidelity is also really important to our
customers so as I mentioned earlier many
of our customers our enterprise
customers and data fidelity is extremely
important to them so making sure that we
deliver all of the data that matches
their rule set so the way that we do
this again is along the same lines of
using a messaging queue and in Twitter
that's eventbus so as I mentioned
between the fire hose and the filtering
layer we have a messaging queue and in
addition to that allowing us to be able
to partition the firehose the other
advantage is is that it allows data to
backup so if there's a big load spike
let's say because of a big event that's
happening then the data would back up
into the messaging Q and the filtering
layer would be able to keep processing
and then it would catch up as the load
starts to level out and so it is
possible that we might get a little bit
behind in the filtering layer but it's
more important that we deliver all of
the data then then it being like
immediate all the time
although we do do consistent load tasks
to ensure that we're able to keep up
with certain levels of volume but in the
case of extreme events sometimes it is
possible that we might get a little bit
behind so we also have the messaging
queue between the filtering layer and
the streaming layer and you'll notice
here that for each of the three
customers you see in the diagram
connected each one of those has their
own messaging queue and so what this
allows us to do is the filtering layer
can publish down to the messaging queue
for each of the customers but the
different customers won't affect each
other so if customer if the customer in
the middle was backing up it
wouldn't affect customer 3 being able to
get their data on time and it all the
other thing that this allows is if there
were to be some sort of network flip or
we do a deploy where the customer gets
guests it gets disconnected they can
request backfill and so what this means
is that we take the pointer from where
the customer's reading to and instead of
reading from current we'll go back a
minute or five minutes or whatever it is
that they specify and just change the
pointer in the queue so that they can
catch up and read the data that they
missed while they were disconnected so
by using this technology and having a
queue per customer we're able to get
them kind of out-of-the-box
functionality that for us was pretty
easy to implement but provides the
customer a lot of a lot of safeguards
around making sure that they have data
fidelity hey so we also use system
redundancy to deal with failures so
obviously be great if things always went
perfect in production but sometimes
things go wrong so we have redundancy in
order to deal with those failures ok so
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
filtering layer so as we talked about
the filtering layer is broken up into
three different stacks which allows us
to separate out the customers from each
other and also to be able to scale as
our customer scale each of those stacks
has multiple applications which allows
us to be able to increase a number of
tweets or change things based on tweet
volume and then on top of that we have
all of this basically replicated so we
have side a and side B where you can see
that for customers 1 through 8 every
single one of those customers is both
inside a and side B so we're filtering
every single customer twice and for us
we chose this approach of having two
different sides because operationally it
makes it really easy to reason about so
we know that we can
a single note on side a and none of the
customers will be impacted because side
B is completely up and healthy we could
actually lose all of side a and
customers would not be impacted and this
is really helpful for things like
deploys because we can deploy side a as
long as side B is healthy because it
does take a bit of time for applications
to come back up once they go down and
the reason for that is because we have
to do all of the loading of the rules
into the index and do all that
pre-processing in order to optimize the
rule evaluation so for us filtering
every customer only once could be
problematic if a node we're to go down
because then they could get delayed data
but by having two sides we make sure
that the customer is being filtered for
in real-time at least once and then if
one node were to have a problem then the
customer would not be impacted so our
goal here is to limit any kind of
customer impact and then in addition to
that if we do have any kind of
operational issues let's say on side a
and it's 2:00 a.m. in the middle of the
night we don't have to worry about
putting in a change really really
quickly and in messing with things and
making a bigger problem in production
because we know that we can kind of take
a deep breath and just kind of move on
with like a thought-out way of
approaching it because the customer
impact is not there they're not being
impacted because side B is healthy so it
also just helps with peace of mind and
being able to make sure that we're
taking the right approach okay so
configuration application this is how we
apply customer configuration in real
time so as we talked about earlier there
in addition to the flow of filtering
customer data they also have a REST API
where they're able to update their rules
in real time and this is essentially a
different product but it's used for
power track in order to be able to
update their rules and the way that we
handle this on the backend is we
have two different mice equal tables one
for rules and one for rule updates and
just to walk through a simple example of
how this would work let's say they added
a rule that was from lm/w
and then they decided my tweets were
actually pretty boring so they deleted
that so you can see that the updates
table is kind of just keeping a log of
what's being updated while the rules
table is actually kind of the this it's
the system of record where we have what
the state of their rules is at that time
then they might decide that they're
interested in learning about hiking and
then that they want to get tweets from
Jack so the advantage of us having the
data stored and these two different
tables is that each filtering
application can then subscribe to the
updates table so that once it has the
rule set loaded it only has to get
updates and this is helpful because if a
customer has 250,000 rules then if they
make a change we don't want to have to
reload all of the rules from the rule
table all we want to do is see what
changed so by the customer subscribing
to the updates table they're able to get
changes in real-time and then they can
simply just add that rule or remove it
without having to reload all the rules
and as I mentioned previously reloading
the rules is a pretty big task because
we have to do all that re-indexing of
the rules and the optimizations so
reloading the entire rule set is not a
super simple task and it's much easier
to simply just apply the updates but we
still keep the rules table completely up
to date because that way when a
filtering application is restarted it
can simply just reload all of the rules
from the existing state also for the
customers to be able to manage their
rules and be able to get all their rules
to see what they are so that they can
make changes to them make sure they
align with what they have in their
system and things like that so the rules
table is the system of record and then
the updates table allows the filtering
applications to be able to apply those
configuration updates in real time
and then the customer can use this REST
API where they're creating and deleting
rules where the customer doesn't even
have to disconnect and so they're able
to continue getting data while all this
is happening in the background so the
way that we handle this behind the
scenes is that the filtering
applications pull for these updates on a
certain interval so we've explored ways
of having the the rule updates to be
pushed to the filter apps but in the
past this hasn't been quite as reliable
and we've ended up implementing polling
anyway so we kind of start with polling
just so that it can make sure that the
data matches what it's supposed to match
but we've talked about in the future
talking having the updates get pushed to
the filtering application so that it can
get applied a little more quickly okay
so in addition to applying rule update
configurations in real time we also can
apply stream configurations in real time
so we have a dashboard where we can
basically see the configuration of the
various sides and stacks and it also
allows us to look at monitoring
statistics like what the lag looks like
when looking at the subscribing to event
bus whether it's behind for a certain
stack whether how long things are taking
to process so how much time it's bending
on the rule evaluation per stack to see
if there's a certain problematic
customer and then based on what we see
in that dashboard and you know based on
certain observability or alerts that
trigger or things that are warnings that
we see or things like that we can use
this dashboard to diagnose and then
mitigate any kind of customer problems
so one thing that you might have noticed
looking at this diagram earlier is that
customers one through eight are both in
side a and side B but the configuration
of customers one through eight is
completely different so stack one on
side AI is completely different than
stack one on side B and this is
intentional and this is to basically
reduce our cost
being able to impact each other so each
of these customers were filtering on
rules that they uploaded and so we try
to put all the mechanisms we can in
place in order to make them not affect
each other but sometimes there might be
things that we miss so if customer one
were able to upload a set of rules that
ended up to be problematic or let's say
some tweet started coming through the
firehose that all of a sudden matched a
ton of their rules just because of some
special event that was going on then it
is possible that stack one could get a
little bit behind and trying to process
that data so on side a that would impact
customers two and three but on side B
customers two and three are not on the
same stack as as customer one so
customers two and three would still
continue to get their data in real time
and not be behind because they're
getting data from side B and so then we
would be able to go into our dashboard
once we realize that stack that customer
one is is problematic and decide to take
any kind of mitigation so if we we have
the option of moving a customer to their
own stack and this is essentially called
quarantine them we have quarantine
stacks where they end up on their own
infrastructure so if they have complex
rules based on a certain event that's
happening having their own
infrastructure gives them the chance to
catch up while we might work with
support and figure out how to reach out
to this customer if their rules need to
be changed if it's a certain problem
with their rule or if we need to make a
code change to be able to optimize for
their for this case that was that was
missed so and then it also would make
the other customers on stack one on side
a which would be two and three no longer
be impacted and so essentially these
stacks would pick up in real-time which
streams are assigned to them and then we
can make those changes in the dashboard
accordingly and this is so this is this
is helpful for us so the filter apps
in the same way that they look for rural
updates they also pull an outside
application that's kind of managing the
state of where each of the of what each
of these workers should be working on
and then they get back the list of
customers that they should be
responsible for so it is possible that
we might move things around we might
decide to add additional nodes to
stack's if the tweet volume starts
increasing and that's all something that
gets applied in real time and it's kind
of unknown to the filter apps they're
simply just working so for example
inside a stack one you can see we have
three filtering applications there and
if we were to decide to add another one
let's say tweet volume increase and we
needed more capacity to be able to
handle all of the volume then we could
add another one there so then that one
would have four filtering applications
and so then instead of each one getting
a third of the fire hose each one would
get a fourth of the fire hose and that's
something that we would just get kind of
out of the box just because we're using
the the messaging queue so each one of
those is using the same identifier for
stack one and so just by adding another
another node that would just all of a
sudden start getting its portion of the
data in the same way if a node were to
go down then well then the ones
remaining would kind of pick up the
slack and it would not be affecting of
the customers getting their data on time
so state management refers to how we
manage the state of our customers across
our different data centers so back to
the system redundancy we talked about
how we have two different sides and how
that allows redundancy so if something
were to go down on one side it's not
affected on the other well you can
basically take that entire diagram and
then duplicate it again because we also
have multiple data centers and this is
really helpful for us in failure
scenarios but it also is a little bit
tricky in terms of me
the state across those data centers so
one particular example of where this
becomes a little tricky is customer
connections so when a customer connects
to us they connect with a certain
identifier for their stream and they
what they will have purchased a certain
amount of connections so let's say that
a customer purchased three connections
that means that they get three redundant
connections and that could be because
they are bringing the data into their
development environment or it could be
because they want redundancy into their
system just for extra backup to make
sure that no tweets are missed if they
were to get disconnected or things like
that and the customer has no knowledge
of which data center they're connected
to so that's all done by routers on on
our side so the customer connects and
then they could be connected to two
different data centers so we have to be
able to communicate across those two
data centers in order to basically make
sure that we're not cutting them off of
connections they should be having but
that were not without that we're also
not giving them a crazy amount of
connections that would hurt our system
so the way that we chose to do this is
using zookeeper and the reason that we
chose zookeeper is because when a
customer connects that then requests
Elise from zookeeper for that stream ID
and then zookeeper just returns back
whether Elise is available or not and so
this took a lot of the overhead of
writing the code away from us and one of
the advantages of this was that the
leases are ephemeral so unlike if we
were to put a record into my sequel or
something like that if a node were to
just go down then the lease would
disappear from zookeeper and we'd no
longer be charging that customer for
that connection whereas if we were to
insert a row into a database then we
would have to figure out some kind of
cleanup process to make sure that the
customer is actually still connected and
that it's not the case that it just
didn't get cleaned up if a node were to
go down or something like that
so using zookeeper and just because by
its nature the leases
ephemeral that kind of takes a lot of
that extra work of figuring out how to
make the notes heartbeat and things like
that away and just kind of gets rid of a
lot of error and we're able to use that
out-of-the-box technology so in addition
the we're using a cluster that's shared
across datacenters so that provides the
the advantage of it working across
datacenter okay so for the powertrack
architecture what we talked about today
was how we filter at scale so how we
basically use predicate indexing and how
we have multiple applications per stack
to be able to filter data at scale how
we're filtering thousands of tweets per
second for our customers hundreds of
thousands of rules how we ensure data
fidelity so basically how we use event
bus or our messaging queue to be able to
back data up into the messaging queue
and ensure that data does not get lost
along the way to our customers how we
have heard onion C of the two different
sides to ensure that we're okay in case
of any kind of failures how we apply
configuration updates in real time such
as rural updates or where a stream is
being filtering from and then lastly how
we manage the state of our customers
across different data centers so that's
the end of my talk and so thanks for
listening and I'm happy to answering any
questions if people have them oh so I
think I heard your question was it's the
two different sides right to the same
stream or different streams is that
correct
so the two sides right to the same
stream and what that allows is the
streaming layer essentially can then
just read directly from that stream so
you might be wondering well doesn't that
end up with duplicate data for the
customer one thing that I didn't mention
so thanks for pointing this out is that
the one
things that the streaming layer does is
d dupes so it kind of keeps a rolling
window of tweets that it looked at in
the last period of time and then does
deduplication based off of the tweet ID
so that we make sure that they don't get
duplicates but it makes it easier from
an operational perspective that it's
only reading from or from one stream
rather than have to coordinate multiple
sure so the question was do we have any
guarantees around fidelity or order and
so around fidelity we in the case that
we were to miss any tweets that would be
considered like a system outage that we
would work with support to post and
communicate to customers so I'm not sure
about like formal SLA s but we do
consider it a production issue if there
were to be a case where data were to be
missing and that's why we have so many
things in place like the the redundancy
and multiple data centers and we have
the messages in the queue in order to
ensure fidelity another piece related to
that is the filtering application
doesn't actually acknowledge that it
read and processed the event until it
processes out to the rendering layer so
it makes sure that the data has actually
been written out and same thing with the
rendering layer it doesn't acknowledge
that it actually read the data until it
writes that out to the customer stream
so this makes sure that it that we don't
lose data if a node were to go down even
because then another node would pick it
up because it's never actually been
acknowledged and then the next part of
your question can you remind me what
that was oh yeah yeah so the order is is
not guaranteed so it's basically
producing the tweets in real-time as
quickly as we can get them out yeah okay
so the question was how do we deal with
production issues it seems like because
the system is pretty complicated that it
would be difficult to kind of nail down
where they she was and I think because
we have it broken down into multiple
different applications it's pretty easy
for us to see where we've seen issues so
you know we'll have error counters and
have that in our monitoring dashboard so
we'll know if we ever weren't able to
publish and event and so I mean for the
most part we get notified of issues in
our system before a customer would even
notice or a lot of the time a customer
doesn't even ever get affected because
it only happens on one side and not the
other side and so it's not actually even
customer impacting so for the most part
based on what the issue is we're able to
kind of narrow it down just because we
have things broken down into discrete
applications that we monitor separately
and I'll have different jobs that
they're responsible for we also have a
QE team that is constantly streaming
data and they're making sure that we're
not missing data from the firehose so
this is really helpful for us so that we
can make sure that this is running in
our staging environment happily before
we ever push that to production so that
definitely helps with just kind of peace
of mind and making sure that things are
fine and we're not pushing those kinds
of bugs to production that would result
in data loss so I think that that we're
out of time but I'm happy to stick
around and I'll be around for the rest
of the conference so if anyone has any
additional questions I'm happy to talk
about it so thank you
[Applause]